larry niven's ringworld is finally about
to get green lit
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
making ring world the tv series has been
in development for uh forever basically
living himself announced back in 2001
that he had a movie deal all signed and
ready to go but that collapsed 2004
sci-fi made its first attempt to make
the tv series that collapsed in 2013
scifi again had a deal with mgm to
create a mini series a four hour mini
series
that collapsed and then in 2017 amazon
bought the rights
but
five years later we still have no ring
world on our tv screens
amazon actually announced that it was
going to be making three very high
budget sci-fi series at the time
ringworld only being one of them
lazarus and snow crash being the other
two
none of these tv series have actually
made it to us tv screens as yet and i
wanted to speak to the people i know mgm
to see if they could tell me anymore so
as you may know if you are a regular
sidetracker i have a couple of people
mgm i talked to and they slipped me a
little bit of gossip here in there
so i asked them straight out what's
happening with ringworld
they've told me that this has been
locked in a quagmire of problems ever
since basically 2017. akiva goldsmith is
still bound to be the showrunner and he
will be the executive producer a
director has even been attached for some
time
and alan taylor is penciled in to direct
the pilot a pilot that has been written
storyboarded there is a bunch of
creative art and concept art apparently
and the whole series is actually planned
out at very least on a drawing board so
what is the hold up
basically i was told that this was
actually ready to go into pre-production
and then covered hit
that
basically stopped everything they were
doing at the time and they had to
prioritize projects and projects that
were already in more further developed
stages of production were prioritized
then the amazon sale to mgm went through
now the first thing i said here was
actually the deal with amazon was to
produce this tv show with mgm so why
would that slow anything down
i might the answer basically was
everything was slowed down
but it wasn't just because of the merger
deal and legal issues over the mgm sale
to amazon um basically over the ftc
inquiry
but another big part of the problem
is that amazon have invested a
significant amount of money recently on
another big project the lord of the
rings
now they paid 250 million dollars and
have already put aside another 500
million dollars to produce the first
series of this lord of the rings prequel
and there is a feeling within ngm that
actually amazon are a little bit
reluctant to sign any more big checks
just yet they already are planning to
develop a stargate series and to get
that onto our screens as quickly as
possible there's the james bond
development that is going to be
expensive and
amazon want to use the now massive
intellectual rights it has
through the mgm sale to remake or reboot
a couple of old classic movies as well
as repackage and redevelop all of their
existing
intellectual properties and obviously
the massive back catalog that they're
now purchasing with the mgm sale
so where does that leave wing world
right now well i am told it is ready to
go it is ready for that green light and
basically this should happen within the
next six months or so
so hopefully at some point in 2023 we'll
actually be getting ring world on our tv
screens
we are actually going to get the lion
bastard flying through space we're going
to see the 200 year old luis wu going on
his first adventure to go and explore
the ring world we're going to find out
what is going on with a puppet master
and meet nessus for the first time what
do you think guys is this a project you
really want to see in our screens is the
ringworld something that you would love
to see
it's one of those projects that is huge
in scope i genuinely think it's a
project that probably couldn't have been
made 10 years ago or 15 years ago best
definitely not from budget amazon will
hopefully be spent on it and with the
absolute
desperation streaming platforms have for
new content i'm absolutely certain this
is about to get made where we are right
now
the director is currently working on
early stages of development they are
tweaking storyboards looking at concept
art akiva goldsman going imdb this guy
he's been involved in so many different
projects over the years including a
major executive producer of a lot of the
star trek franchises at the moment he's
working on strange new worlds at the
moment he's working on picard he's
worked on several other projects
including actually fringe which is one
of my favorite tv shows back in the day
he is working on again developing this
tv series and working hard to get it
just right
because this is a loved novella this is
a loved story they are going to have to
get it right and there are elements of
story that are slightly insane which
make it very easy to wander into the
silly
getting the tone right for this series
is going to be incredibly difficult and
a bit of a challenge so i'm kind of glad
in a way that they've been forced to
take a pause a pause that will then
hopefully see the fruits of when it does
finally make our screens
so that's it guys
ringworld is coming to our tv screens in
the next 18 months or so get into the
comments tell me what you think is this
something you're looking forward to
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out you
can also become a fully fledged
sidetracker and support the channel by
hitting the join button below
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time